there's more to the Five Nights at
Freddy's movie than just creepy
mechanical monsters and jump scares
though there are plenty of those too
let's dig into what all that Mayhem
really
meant the film's protagonist Mike
Schmidt suffers from anxiety that's
spurred by a traumatic incident from his
childhood when Mike was a kid his
younger brother Garrett was abducted
while they were on a camping trip now as
an adult he uses his dreams to figure
out who took him with no success not
only does this nightmare cause him to
struggle to keep a job but it also
affects his relationship with his
younger sister Abby who cares for by
himself Mike's newest job a seemingly
harmless nighttime security gig at a
closed children's party venue called
Freddy Fazbear's Pizza quickly becomes
unsettling when the animatronics come to
life at night at first they appear
friendly as they develop a strong bond
with Abby unfortunately that's only a
ruse so they can manipulate Mike's
desire for answers about Garrett the
animatronic characters ultimately make a
deal with him for Abby Mike regretfully
accepts and the friendly characters turn
violent to please their unseen Master
Mike is nearly killed by his Newfound
animatronic at foes but he's rescued by
his friend Vanessa who discloses
everything she knows about Freddy's have
you met them
yet met who this includes that her
Father William Aton is the orchestrator
of this nightmare and that the
animatronics that Mike has been dealing
with have a horrific past to their
own decades ago afon the mysterious
owner of Freddy Fazbear's Pizza brought
Freddy and the other animatronics to
Life by kidnapping children and stuffing
them into the mechanical mascots this
caused their souls to be intertwined
with the Machinery now after controls
them through drawings that influen their
beliefs and is looking to add another
child Abby to his collection they want
to make her like them now knowing all
this Mike heads back to Freddy fazbears
to stop Freddy Mike runs into Apton who
reveals himself to be the guy who gave
Mike this job under the name Steve
Raglin with his own mechanized yellow
bunny suit Apon senselessly beats Mike
he's only thwarted by Abby who uses her
own drawings at show Freddy and the
others what Apon did to them she
convinces them to betray Apon just as
the spring traps in his C costume cause
him to be locked in it forever as the
building falls apart Freddy and his
companions pull Apon away while Mike and
Abby help a severely injured Vanessa
Escape sometime later Mike visits
Vanessa in the hospital and shares a
family dinner with Abby promising that
they could see Freddy again one day
meanwhile one of the ghost children
leaves Aton behind a locked door so that
he suffers the same Fates as his
victims at the start of the film Mike
blames himself for Garrett's abduction
searching for answers years after his
disappearance he even recreates and
relives Garrett being taken through his
dreams just to find Clues his
frustrations from his failures also
drive him to be incredibly cold towards
Abby he cruy chastises her for having
imaginary friends seemingly wishing that
Garrett was there instead of her that's
what makes him so vulnerable to the
ghost children who inhabit Freddy and
his cronies he nearly loses Abby because
of that pain Mike instantly regrets his
initial decision to trade Abby for
Garrett and does everything he can to
fix things he realizes that Abby is just
as important to him as Garrett was and
sets out to stop Freddy from turning
Abby into an animatronic when Mike gets
a moment alone with Abby he apologizes
for how he treated her and dedicates
himself to being a better brother based
on the film's ending Mike seems to live
up to that promise he now acts as a
better parental figure for Abby sharing
dinner with her just like their family
used to do Mike turns things around for
himself and has the potential for a
better relationship with Abby no longer
trapped by his
guilt as Mike finds a sort of redemption
Aton finally gets punished for his
horrible crimes in the climactic final
battle Aton is slowly cut down by the
spring traps in his animatronic suit and
becomes stuck inside it as he bleeds out
and the building falls apart he's
dragged away we don't see what happens
to him until the final scene raon is in
one of the back rooms the ghost children
leave him there for dead he's still
alive but not going anywhere anytime
soon the owner is just not ready to let
it go yet the ghost children and the
mechanical monsters they inhabit are no
longer under aton's control thanks to
the picture that Abby draws of Apon
killing the children the magic bind that
Aton has over Freddy and the other
animatronics is broken they're fully
able to act on their own and it's a key
reason why they all turn on Apon in the
end now Freddy and his friends are more
powerful than Apton leaving him to the
same fate they suffered before they died
it's hard to say whether Apton will
simply die now or if this could be the
start of his return is a larger than
life nightmare but at least for now his
reign of terror has come to an
end the personal trauma Mike deals with
is the emotional core of Five Nights at
Freddy's the film's depiction of how
lingering grief can lead someone to lose
themselves is a horror in itself
although Mike's erratic behavior and
cruel treatment of Abby make him tough
to like at first it's hard not to feel
something for him as his trauma becomes
clear he's so desperate to find any
resolution to what happened to Garrett
that it's the only thing he dreams about
his hunger for the truth runs so deep
that he uses his sleeping pills to fall
into a deep Slumber so that his dreams
are more surreal his residual anxiety
causes him to lash out at others
including a man he mistakenly thinks is
kidnapping a child the film's depiction
of Mike's stress is easily relatable to
anyone who struggles to let go of the
past or is haunted by it it drives him
to put Abby in Peril and consumes him so
greatly that it detaches es from reality
entirely it's what makes Mike's growth
so impactful and there are some great
moments like Mike's apology to Abby and
the realization of his mistakes that
emphasize him coming out of his own
Darkness although Five Nights at
Freddy's features five main ghost
children who have distinct connections
to Freddy and his machine allies there
are surely more Aton clearly has a
pattern of abducting children and the
fact that he took Garrett so long ago
likely means that he's been doing this
for quite a while it's very probable
that Aton has put other children into
Mech suits over the years and some of
the other characters seen in the
background could signify past attempts
in the back room that characters walk in
and out of throughout the film there's a
dog character possibly a reference to
the urban legend of Sparky from the
games seen lying down there's also that
horrifying looking husk that looks
suspiciously like circus baby that Abby
is nearly put into they're broken apart
now but maybe these once house the kids
Apon took at some point the possibility
of there being more ghost children is
especially strong considering that there
are a lot more characters from the game
still to make their debut aton's
obsession with building these go goofy
animatronics and putting kids in them
sadly has a long history so who knows
how many ghost kids are really out there
it's safe to say that there are more
than
five the ambiguity surrounding Garrett's
fate makes it very possible that he's
another ghost that Mike and Abby could
meet in the near future although afon
admits to having taken Garrett when Mike
was a kid he's not exactly clear about
what happened to him he says that
Garrett is gone but that could just mean
that he was stuffed into one of the
animatronics this mystery has strong
potential to keep Mike and Abby around
in the franchise and give them personal
motivation to look for more of Freddy's
companions the reemergence of Garrett as
a ghost child also could help them fill
in the gaps of what happened while he
was with Afton it could lead to more
explanation of how Aton brings these
animatronics to life as well as who he
really is especially since Aton is
largely absent throughout most of the
film Garett could be the key to really
understanding Apon in this weird world
where ghosts and machines combined to
create uncanny
Horrors the fates of Freddy and his pals
are also left ambiguous and could have
some strong implications for what's next
in their story the control that Aton has
had over them is now destroyed so
they're basically free to do whatever
they want after they leave Aton to
either die or become merged with his
costume the characters could leave the
place altogether and find somewhere else
to call home maybe they go and find Abby
to rekindle their friendship or perhaps
their exit from Freddy Fazbear's Pizza
could result in them visiting some of
the other locations from the games
longtime Five Nights at Freddy's fans
know that as more sequels came out the
series continually expanded outside of
Freddy Fazbear's Pizza perhaps the next
film could be the right time to bring
fans to Freddy's Frights horror Centric
attraction that acted as the third game
setting or there's potential for the
characters to explore the sister
location from the fifth game circus
babies entertainment and Rental and
introduce circus baby to the mix the
options are wide open for what Freddy
and his friends are up to especially now
that they seem to be fully autonomous
there are ghost children possessing
giant
robots thanks for the heads up there's
currently no confirmation of a sequel to
Five Nights at Freddy's going into
development but the chances of it
happening are very high the film already
made its money back before it even hit
theaters thanks to the sale of streaming
and Theatrical distribution rights so
what could happen in a potential sequel
the ending of the film doesn't give many
hints nor does the mid credit scene
since it's basically just a fun scare
gag with the balloon boy statue we can
guess though that the movies will
probably continue the story of the games
remixing some of the events and
introductions it's worth noting that the
film doesn't follow the games beat for
beat and introduces things that don't
appear until later games for instance
springtrap who is represented by aton's
costume choice doesn't appear until the
third game this means that other unseen
characters and locations can appear at
any point the sequel could also weave
together plot points from the other
games to create a narrative cocktail of
the franchise's best parts so while a
Five Nights at Freddy's sequel is almost
certainly on the horizon it won't
exactly be predictable for fans of the
games when Matthew Lillard who plays
Apton appeared on the weekly MTG podcast
to talk about magic the Gathering he
also revealed some interesting
information about his contract I just
got cast in a movie called Five Nights
at Freddy's it's a three picture deal
with universal and and Blum House unless
Lillard is also planning to appear in
other Universal and blumhouse projects
as part of that deal it can be assumed
that he's going to be part of a five
nights Trilogy this news lines up with
director Emma Tommy's desire to see the
films be the start of a franchise she'd
like to return to Tommy told Screen Rant
that there's so much more for potential
sequels to explore saying oh my gosh
well the lore is massive there was no
way we were ever going to fit everything
into one film nor was it the intention
so the answer is yes there's so much to
potentially bring into any sequels
should we be lucky enough to make them
so according to those directly involved
fans can have at least some expectation
of more Five Nights at Freddy's films
that delve deeper into the
[Music]
lore